We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Morris. In the world of Philip K. Dick, humans are often at the mercy of objects, like taxis, coffee makers, and doors. Here's a scene from his book, Ubik.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内进行合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·莫里斯。在菲利普·K·迪克的作品世界里，人类往往受制于各种物体，比如出租车、咖啡机和门。以下是他书作《尤比克》中的一个片段。
The door refused to open. It said, five cents please. Joe Chip refused to open. It said 5 cents please. Joe Chips searched his pockets. No more coins, nothing. I'll pay you tomorrow he told the door. Again he tried the knob. Again it remained locked tight. From the drawer besides the sink, Joe got a stainless steel knife.
门拒绝打开。它说，请付五分钱。乔·奇普拒绝打开。它说，请付五分钱。乔·奇普搜遍了口袋。没有硬币了，什么都没有。我明天付给你，他告诉那扇门。他又试了试门把手。它依然紧锁。乔从水槽旁边的抽屉里拿出一把不锈钢刀。
With it he began systematically to unscrew the bolt assembly of his money gulping door. I'll sue you, the door said, as the first screw fell out. That's Benjamin Walker. He told me he's always subscribed to Dix' dystopian vision of man versus object. But then he met up with Paula Antonelli. Philip K. Dix' view of the future of objects was definitely dystopian and he needed it for like drama reasons. But in truth, we've had a report with objects throughout the centuries. I mean there's always been affection, emotion, heirloom
他用刀开始系统地拧下那扇贪财之门的螺栓组件。我会起诉你的，门说道，随着第一颗螺丝掉落。那是本杰明·沃克。他告诉我，他一直认同迪克关于人与物体对立的反乌托邦愿景。但后来他遇到了保拉·安东内利。菲利普·K·迪克对物体未来的看法绝对是反乌托邦的，他出于戏剧性的原因需要这种设定。但事实上，几个世纪以来，我们一直与物体保持着某种联系。我的意思是，一直以来都有情感、爱意，比如传家宝
ring or the bridge where you had your first kiss. I mean there's always been an attachment. There's a whole universe in every single object that becomes even bigger when put in relationship with a person. Paula Antonelli is a senior curator in the Department of Architecture and Design at the Museum of Modern Art. Her most recent blockbuster show, Talk to Me, examined the future and the history of communication design. Furniture design or car design is just one fragment of the design world.
戒指，或者是你们第一次接吻的那座桥。我的意思是，总有一种依恋。每一个物体中都有一个完整的宇宙，当它与人建立联系时，这个宇宙会变得更加宏大。保拉·安东内利是现代艺术博物馆建筑与设计部的高级策展人。她最近的重磅展览“与我交谈”审视了传播设计的未来与历史。家具设计或汽车设计只是设计世界的一个片段。
And for many years there's been something called communication design, which maybe before used to be called graphic design, which is the design of messages, be it advertising or be it, you know, just signage. So it's existed. So that's design whose subject is communication. But right now, the difference is that even furniture designers need to understand that a chair might need to have some kind of conversation with people. There was a talking chair in her show.
多年来，一直存在着所谓的传播设计，以前可能被称为平面设计，即信息的传达设计，无论是广告还是仅仅是标识。所以它一直存在。这就是以传播为主题的设计。但现在，不同之处在于，即使是家具设计师也需要明白，一把椅子可能需要与人进行某种对话。她的展览中就有一把会说话的椅子。
This is the arrow in which chairs can talk. I think it can talk, they can sing. And talking toys and talking maps, but there were also ATMs and subway kiosks. According to Paula Antonelli, cutting edge communication design is all about the interface. When you say interface, you can take out the face and put section, you can take out section and put relation.
这是一个椅子可以说话的时代。我认为它们不仅能说话，还能唱歌。还有会说话的玩具和地图，但也有自动取款机和地铁售票亭。根据保拉·安东内利的说法，尖端传播设计的核心在于界面。当你提到界面（interface）时，你可以去掉“面”（face），换成“部分”（section），或者去掉“部分”，换成“关系”（relation）。
I mean, it's one of the focal points of the way we live today and the way culture moves today. Paula Antonelli says, designers understand the interface between people and objects better than say science fiction writers because what they're really working on is the interface between people and people. One of the pieces she put in her show was a menstruation machine designed by Sputniko.
我的意思是，这是我们今天生活方式和文化发展方式的焦点之一。保拉·安东内利说，设计师比科幻小说作家更了解人与物体之间的界面，因为他们真正致力于研究的是人与人之间的界面。她在展览中展出的作品之一是由 Sputniko 设计的月经机。
And in that particular case, the interface is not between man and machine. It's between man and woman, right? So it's a contraption that looks like a chestety belt that it's for men, but also for men or puzzle women. And it really gives you the feeling of a menstruation. It has electrodes, the stimulator lower abdomen, and they give you cramps. And then it has a reservoir in the back. You're supposed to draw your blood, put it in there and then you have your blood drip exactly where it should.
在那个特定的案例中，界面不是人与机器之间的，而是男人与女人之间的，对吧？所以这是一个看起来像贞操带的装置，它是为男性设计的，但也适用于男性或女性。它确实能让你感受到月经的感觉。它有电极，刺激下腹部，让你产生痉挛。然后后面有一个储液器。你需要抽取自己的血液，放进去，然后让血液准确地滴在它应该滴的地方。
So it's the whole shabang and to me it's the ultimate gesture of understanding and that's what I really love. That interface, not the human machine interface. The human machine interface, you know what? We are all doing engineers, designers, scientists. We're all trying to make technology disappear. That's the truth. Just like we go through the toll booths in freeways using easy paths, and we still have that box, but we don't think about it. That's how life should be, so that we can focus
所以这就是全部过程，对我来说，这是理解的终极姿态，这正是我真正喜欢的地方。那个界面，而不是人机界面。人机界面，你知道吗？我们所有的工程师、设计师、科学家都在努力让技术消失。这是事实。就像我们使用 Easy Pass 通过高速公路收费站一样，我们仍然有那个盒子，但我们不会去想它。生活本该如此，这样我们才能专注于
on real human habits and human needs as opposed to focusing on the technology. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Benjamin Walker, who produces the radio program too much information from WFMU. He also sports a Philip K. Dick inspired Yubik Tattoo on his arm. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, local public radio 91.7 in San Francisco. The American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture
真正的人类习惯和需求，而不是专注于技术。《99%隐形》本周由本杰明·沃克制作，他也制作了 WFMU 的广播节目《信息过载》。他的手臂上还有一个受菲利普·K·迪克《尤比克》启发的纹身。本节目由 Lunar 支持制作，以创造力创造改变。这是旧金山公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 的一个项目。旧金山建筑师协会和建筑与设计中心也提供了支持。
and Design. This program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange, making public radio more public, more at prx.org. Our intern is Sam Greenspan. To find out more about this show, and listen to past episodes, there's like 43 of them. It's on the website at 99%Invisible.org. We won't get far. Fly in circles inside the jaw. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本节目由公共广播交流平台 PRX 发行，旨在让公共广播更加普及，更多信息请访问 prx.org。我们的实习生是萨姆·格林斯潘。要了解更多关于本节目的信息并收听过往剧集（大约有 43 集），请访问网站 99%Invisible.org。我们走不远。在下颚里盘旋。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。